- We have some great big
pieces here at the Bellagio.
- [Narrator] This is Jerry Bolan.
- Here's our water goddess of
spring in the conservatory.
She's 32 feet tall.
- [Narrator] He's the executive
director of horticulture
at the Bellagio.
Jerry takes care of Las
Vegas' secret garden,
a serene oasis hidden away
from the hustle and bustle
of the strip.
- These are my plants, and this is my show.
- [Narrator] Jerry doesn't do it alone.
Ed Libby is the creative
genius behind it all.
- My name is Ed Libby, and
this is the secret garden
of Las Vegas.
- [Narrator] Five times a
year, Ed designs a new floral
wonderland for the
Bellagio Conservatory and
Botanical Gardens.
- My career started kind of by accident.
I was a driver in a flower
shop while I was in school
for set design, and my
career kind of snowballed
after that.
- [Narrator] Thirty-four years
later, as creative director,
Ed is churning out elaborate
landscaping masterpieces.
- I think everything about
the Bellagio is completely
unique to Vegas.
I mean, it's completely over the top.
This is not something that
people see in real life.
As people get closer to it,
we call it the up-close magic,
and they realize that the
flowers are made out of
other flowers and that
the 14-foot birds are made
out of seeds, and the
beautiful water goddess
from the sea with a pearl in
her hand is made out of moss.
- [Narrator] And once
Ed's designs are given the
green light, Jerry and
his team get to work.
- Morning, Travis!
- [Narrator] And it's a lot of work.
To bring the floral fantasy to life,
the gardens are closed to
the public and a team of
125 transforms the space.
- [Jerry] During one show,
we'll go through about
80,000 flowers.
- [Narrator] And the flowers
are just the beginning.
There's also 40-foot props.
- Naturally one question
I always get asked:
how do we get these big
props in the conservatory
in the middle of the hotel?
- [Narrator] The larger
installations are brought
in pieces no larger
than 10 feet by 10 feet.
This is the only way the team can get them
through the door.
(upbeat music)
- We also use a crane.
- [Narrator] And it's more
than just heavy lifting
and gardening.
- We bring in a feng shui
master for Chinese new years.
- [Narrator] All in the name of beauty and
cultural accuracy.
- I don't think that anybody
really understands what
it is until they come here.
It's really this incredibly
lush oasis in the middle
of the Las Vegas strip.
- [Narrator] Together,
Ed and Jerry have created
a uniquely tranquil place
that could only exist
in Vegas.
Equal parts glamour and zen.